à Monsieur Tellier, directeur
à Hydro-Québe
D'abord Pascal. Est-ce normal
des vents au mois de décembre de
- On a des vents toute l'année.u
des vents les plus violents.
Ce qu'on observe à l'aéroport,
105 km à l'heure, elle bat un
record.
Le record était à 103.
On les bat pas de beaucoup, mai.
11 décembre 1975 à 103 à 103 à a
battu à 105.
Mais quand même, on a eu affaire
à une tempête qui a
relie à la tornade. Cela même
système qui provoque les tornade
et le temps violent qui apporte
de l'pluie verglaçante.
Je vous disais déjà depuis jeudi
qu'il y avait de fort vent et
venir les monstres.
La tempête est très vaste et
recouvre l'tiers
qu'on a observé. Ça se
passe à l'arrière du système et
c'est là qu'on voit al
le plus fort.
La pression se met à monter très
rapide- Ce que va vous demanderi
vous travaillez pris notre
Québec, notre in
demanderait c'est est-ce que ça
va se produire encore de plus en
On sa On sa On sa On sa On sa t
plus extrême, le problème
connaît des vents violents. On a
calcul on a eu des
vents tout aussi fort le 1ernovt
à ce qu'on observait par le
passé, voici les vents les plus
violents envers
160 km à l'h à l'h à l'h à l'h .
t vraiment que les vents
les plus violents, s'éparpiller
dans la saison. De fortes
tempêtes qui passent.
est très fort, mais on a
eu des pervers dans le passé.
On est peut-être cette Moravec
105 km à l'heure.alement, valeml
n'y a pas de tornade. Je reviena
créé des tornade exceptionnelle
au Kentucky.
- Une tornade cette puissance di
meurtrière, on envoie très
rarement en décembre. C'es
rare, lement
impossible. Envoi des tornades
de cette force armée. C'est là
qu'on allait tornade la plus
violente. En 201
tornades par Noël, pas aussi
puissant que cela, mais c'était
aux États-Unis. C'était
autre registre.
On est rendu à 74 morts.
Possiblement une puissance très
forte. Quatre foies plus forts
sud du Québec le samedi soir.
- Coplus.
- Le climat change.
Ce n'e